en 2019 je vais faire un rapport sur le
déclin de l'agriculture française en
disant qu'elle était passée du deuxième
rang mondial au 6e rang et que se déclin
était sans cesse qu'en augmentation 70%
de l'explication de ce déclin est lié à
un autre manque de compétitivité ou un
autre perte de compétitivité au niveau
agricole
la première c'est des charges plus
élevées que nos concurrents la main
d'oeuvre en particulier une fois et demi
plus élevée en France qu'en Allemagne 7
fois plus élevé en Espagne 12 fois plus
élevés qu'à en Pologne et 70 fois plus
élevé qu'au Maroc la deuxième des
charges plus importante que nous
connaissons dans notre pays c'est la
problématique des surtranspositions ce
qui fait que les agriculteurs français
ont moins de moyens que les agriculteurs
européens ou mondiaux et donc se
retrouvent dans une concurrence déloyale
la deuxième explication c'est une guerre
des prix entre l'industrie
agroalimentaire et la grande
distribution qui fait que l'industrie
agroalimentaire ne dégage que de moins
en moins de bénéfices et donc à de moins
en moins de capacité à investir et donc
par définition n'ayant pas ses capacités
d'investissement diminuent en
productivité et en compétitivité au
profit de nos concurrents européens au
mondiaux la troisième explication de
notre manque de compétitivité c'est un
État français pas suffisamment
protecteur ce qui fait que nous signons
des contrats de libre-échange au niveau
européen la France ne suit pas ses
contrats de échanges la France ne
renégocie pas ses contrats de
libre-échange et petit à petit et bien
tous ceux à qui on a laissé commencer de
faire des productions pour les acheter
en les importants sur l'entrée de gamme
et bien petit à petit prennent au fur et
à mesure toute la valeur ajoutée c'est
l'exemple de la tomate marocaine qui
commence par la tomate ronde d'entrée de
gamme en 1996 qui nous pousse dans
l'obligation de produits d'arrêter de
produire cette tomate ronde pour faire
de la tomate grappe les Marocains font
de la tomate gras nous poussent à faire
de la tomate cerise les Marocains font
de la tomate cerise et aujourd'hui il
nous laisse uniquement la possibilité
quasiment de faire que des tomates
anciennes ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui le
kilo de tomates français se retrouve à 5
à 7 euros le kilo et que la plupart des
tomates achetées en France et bien sur
marocaine la quatrième cause de notre
manque de compétitivité c'est un climat
médiatico-politique qui sans cesse
vivant de l'agriculture française ce qui
n'est pas le cas dans d'autres pays en
Italie par exemple les Italiens sont des
ambassadeurs des produits et de la
gastronomie italienne en France vous
avez de plus en plus de procureurs de
l'agriculture française L214 condamne
les élevages de poulet de 3000 à 6000
poulets en France comme étant
industriels et dans le même temps on en
produit de moins en moins la
consommation mon doigt mondiale est sans
cesse en augmentation et nous ouvrons
les portes au poulet ukrainien qui est
alimenté dans des bâtiments de 60 000
poulets valeur actuelle nous avons une
augmentation du poulet ukrainien sur nos
étals de plus de 145%. donc cette naïve
découpable nous conduit avoir régressé
de plus en plus notre modèle agricole
[Musique]
le premier c'est d'étendre la situation
normative pour arrêter de sur transposer
pour trouver enfin les éléments qui nous
permettent de rester dans la course de
rester dans la compétitivité arrêtez de
toujours être en train de donner des
injonctions contradictoires que plus
personne ne comprend arrêtez aussi
d'être dans des évolutions qui ne vont
pas dans le sens de ce que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui le tout monté en
gamme nous conduit aujourd'hui à ne plus
produire l'entrée de gamme et la moyenne
gamme ce qui fait que nous faisons que
des produits de haute valeur ajoutée
mais par contre dans une situation comme
celle actuelle où on a une forte
augmentation de l'inflation et bien le
panier de la ménagère ne pouvant plus se
payer ce haut de gamme et bien c'est au
détriment d'une multitude et de plus en
plus importante d'importation donc il
faut que nous ayons cette capacité de
regarder les choses en face et
d'apporter des solutions donc à travers
ces articles nous allons essayer de
détendre la situation normative et
réglementaire nous allons essayer de
donner des moyens aux agriculteurs pour
retrouver la fierté de produire donc ça
passe par des possède à l'investissement
tant pour traiter la problématique des
aléas climatiques mais aussi pour
surtout traiter la problématique de la
compétitivité rendre nos exploitations
plus compétitives et enfin la troisième
possibilité le troisième axe c'est
l'innovation de façon à ce que nous ne
soyons pas que dans un message
rétrograde et que nous ne regardions pas
le programme comme étant une chance
aujourd'hui nous avons la possibilité
par l'intelligence en marque et par les
drones et autres de pouvoir traiter ces
problématiques d'utilisation des
produits phytosanitaires en les
réduisant par ces nouvelles technologies
et par l'innovation et bien il ne faut
pas s'en cacher il ne faut pas jouer la
politique de l'autruche et au contraire
les mettre en avant et c'est ce que nous
allons faire à travers ces 26 articles
je pense que pendant trop longtemps nous
avons sans cesse condamné notre modèle
agricole alors que nous avons un modèle
qui est très vertueux nous avons un
modèle qui est resté sur une situation
d'expression familiale avec des capitaux
qui appartiennent aux familles des
agriculteurs nous avons conservé une
agriculture qui serait partie sur
l'ensemble de du pays avec des régions
qui sont extraordinairement belles à
regarder en de paysages mais aussi à
déguster à travers les produits du
terroir et la gastronomie française je
pense que la seule chose qu'il faut que
nous donnions c'est redonner confiance
aux agriculteurs leur redonner la fierté
penser que nous n'avons pas à leur
donner des injonctions sans cesse pour
savoir ce qu'ils ont à faire il n'y a
pas un métier qui est aussi critiqué que
le métier d'agriculteur donc arrêtons
d'être là dedans laissons un peu plus
faisons confiance à nos agriculteurs
laissons les produire pour que non
seulement ils puissent produire
l'alimentation des français mais aussi
se nourrir de leur travail
[Musique]